est-ce que maintenant pour le président
américain Joe Biden alors qu'il avait
multiplié les discussions au sein de son
parti dans la perspective d'un votre du
congrès sur ton plan d'investissement un
sénateur semble avoir enterré cette
réforme on en parle justement avec notre
correspondant à Washington Thomas bonnet
Thomas Bonsoir Jean a déclaré ce weekend
qu'il ne voterai pas pour ce plan
d'investissement quelles conséquences
Thomas pour la Maison Blanche
et bien c'est tout simplement la mesure
certainement la plus importante et la
plus ambitieuse de Joe Biden qui
pourrait ne jamais voir le jour on sait
que les discussions patine autour de ce
plan d'investissement depuis des mois un
plan qui a déjà été approuvé à la
Chambre des représentants mais qui est
donc toujours bloqué au Sénat et en fait
il y a un homme qui exerce ce blocage
c'est le sénateur démocrate de l'Etat de
Virginie occidentale Jumanji alors il
s'est entretenu a de très nombreuses
reprises avec Joe Bayonne au courant des
derniers mois pour tenter de trouver un
accord encore la semaine dernière les
deux hommes ont échangé à la
Maison-Blanche mais cela n'a visiblement
pas suffi puisque voici ce qu'a déclaré
Jumanji nous ce weekend sur l'antenne de
fox news écouter
c'est un nom pour cette loi j'ai essayé
tout ce qui était humainement possible
je ne peux pas le faire j'ai toujours
dit cela si je ne peux pas rentrer chez
moi elle expliqué aux habitants de
Virginie occidentale je ne peux pas voté
pour et je ne peux pas voter pour
continuer cette partie de la loi je ne
peux juste pas
Jumanji 1 qui évoque ce lundi un
comportement inacceptable de la part des
équipes de la Maison-Blanche sans en
dire davantage alors son vote est
indispensable pour faire passer c'est
toi puisque la majorité démocrate au
Sénat et très court évidemment beaucoup
de personnes au sein du Parti démocrate
en très vivement critiqué sa prise de
position tel que Bernie Sanders ou
encore Alexandria ocasio Cortez et à
l'inverse du côté des républicains
beaucoup ont salué cette décision du
sénateur qui est pourtant donc à
démocrate la Maison Blanche a également
vivement réagi ce weekend par la voix de
la porte-parole de la Maison Blanche qui
a souligné un retournement de veste de
la part de sénateurs démocrate qui comme
cela a été rappeler assez non nombre de
reprise entretenu avec le président Joe
Bayonne pour parler de ce plan alors ce
plan d'investissement pour rappel c'est
un plan titanesque de 2000 milliards de
dollars qui prévoit notamment de large
réforme sur le volet social ou encore
environnemental pour les opposants ce
qui bloque c'est surtout le financement
de ce plan d'investissement parce qu'ils
estiment que cela va faire monter les
impôts à des contribuables américains en
tout cas du parti du côté du Parti
démocrate il y a encore un peu
d'optimisme ce lundi on va certainement
retourner à la table des négociations
pour tenter de trouver un accord d'ici
l'année prochaine en tout cas ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que ce sénateur
démocrate je mange Chine est en train de
gâcher les fêtes de fin d'année de Joe
Biden qu'il en avait certainement pas
besoin merci Thomas en direct donc de
Washington